da willkommen meine lieben freunde ihr
seht ihr schon hinter mir
gar nichts denn wenn ihr dieses video
hier gerade seht bin ich bereits
zurückgezogen nach köln wenn ihr weitere
updates dazu haben wollte der immer
instagram vorbei mit laser luca darum
sollte allerdings nicht gehen denn ihr
seht es bereits im titel ich spiele
heute zum ersten mal doodle jump das
immer mit 16 17 oder soll ich das mal
gespielt gelöscht weil es nicht gut
vernetzt ist medial runtergeladen wir
sind natürlich 99 jahre alt und dann
befinden wir uns jetzt ja auch schon
eine gute chance aber lädt die app
überhaupt
schon mal alles lesen ist perfekt der
erste sache direktwerbung es gibt ein
multiplayer
oder wieder egal wir kriegen auf jeden
fall aufspielen und befinden uns direkt
in einer map wir sind ach guck mal die
kann ich gar nicht runterfallen
ok also wir müssen uns auf jeden fall
steuern indem wir hier so ein bisschen
links rechts machen hier oben ist ein
monster da dürfen wir nicht rein fliegen
wir können aber auch mainz darauf dass
weiß noch
was sind denn das für high scores am
rand sind das sind alles freunde von mir
die
hüpfen mal hier vorne ruf hier auf dann
hier ich kann jetzt schon nicht mehr
reden das ist ja übels ist findet man
hier so
[Musik]
ich kann ich da ich habe vergessen dass
wenn ich ja hochspringen dass das dann
unten weg gehen weil darunter war
eigentlich noch im block frei aber wieso
ist mein score jetzt 25 0
[Musik]
hier spielen allerdings direkt nochmal
jungen ist wieder das tutorial also
erstmal kurz ihr rechts drauf zack auf
das monster diesmal nicht jetzt gehen
wir hier springen wie hoch ich werde auf
jeden fall immer besser von london sage
ich euch werde jetzt nicht verlieren
sagt hier hoch sagt hier hochkommt mal
oben da ist man heiß gewesen da rechts
tag hier weiter hier weiter ach kummer
jedem app ist tatsächlich
unterschiedlich dachte das war immer der
gleiche mann sowie bei flirt oder wie
das hieße ja auch alles gleich war aber
man dem ansprechen von einerseits immer
schwieriger wurde aber gut die blauen
teile bewegen sich es gibt auch löcher
dessen transport
es war in dieser situation gerade
schwieriger in das loch rhein zu fliegen
als außen rum zu springen deswegen
dachte ich es wäre vielleicht was gut
ist und man springt dann hinter dem
papier her und wird oben wieder raus
gelingt ist aber in ordnung daher sind
wir hier direkt wieder in einer neuen
map hier oben schnell darauf auf die
feder tag hier auf die feder am ersten
heizkörper nicht vorbei mein zweiter
heißt kommen ist zugleich kommen ich
will dieses ding da oben für meinen nein
ich wollte diese komische mit mit dem
propeller dran aber gut
ist das irgendwie verpackt bei mir dass
das trampolin gerade nicht reagiert hat
aber gut wir springen hier weiter hoch
das ist schon selten gesehen hiermit
können jetzt guck mal damit können wir
durch wir uns dadurch bringen wird so
ein schallschutz haben hier vorne was
und das ist irgendwie so
trampolinspringer auch okay das ist so
wie wenn ich diese komische feder die
ganze zeit quasi hätte aber die habe ich
jetzt nicht immer oder oder verliert
wenn ich jetzt analog kann ich von dir
nicht gegen die monster springen wie bei
super mario wenn ich dann irgendwie weil
sie eine blume zum feuer schießen habe
das wenn man dann gegen den anderen
league gegen den gegner oder so dass man
dann die blume verliert aber zumindest
noch groß ist und noch weiter leben kann
wie so ein extra leben und ihr drauf
zack hoch hier drauf es ist schon echt
crazy was ist der hsv euch denn gerade
was das
ok dann kann ich mich auch noch relativ
übel geil das ist so wie bei mario kart
wenn man auf dieser wenn man da diese
bullets rakete hat was sind das die die
weißen muss ich jetzt daran oder nicht
so ok die weizen verschwinden das geht
ja weiter ich muss es gerade uncut
lassen weil ich einfach hier nicht viel
schneiden kann weil es ja jederzeit sein
kann dass irgendwas passiert aber ich
glaube stell mich gar nicht mal so doch
ok ok mit dem propeller kann ich die
teile auf jeden fall auch mit nehme ich
dachte schon ich hätte dennoch irgendwie
ausreichen müssen
ist das
mein gott
wie soll ich denn machen
[Musik]
21.500 26
das sollte erstmal einer nachmachen hier
spielt allerdings noch mal und haben
jetzt zu beginn tatsächlich gar nicht
distel mehr unten das heißt die app weiß
mittlerweile hey wir haben es hier mit
einem glasklaren profi zu tun 21.000
punkte die macht man nicht mal einfach
so kuck mal jemand erster heiße ohren
vorbei ich will einfach schnellstmöglich
hoch kann man sich irgendwie so sachen
kaufen das nicht irgendwie ich fünf euro
bezahlt habe ich in jeder runde
irgendwie warnung sehen denn häufig
jetzt den chip sich eingesammelt gerade
aber gut kann ja sein dass man irgendwie
fünf euro bezahlt dass ich in jeder
runde mir aussuchen kann vor der runde
was mitnehmen will irgendwie im gepäck
im item spot irgendwie eine rakete fünf
springer und irgendwie zwei schutz oder
sorgt das geht nicht was machen die hier
kommen die je nach oben und unten ok ok
sehr gut hier weiter hoch das korn hier
die ganze zeit oder wir besiegen die
ganze zeit diese leute die so nicht denn
gleich wenn ich da oben bin wie soll ich
dann in monster vorbei ich glaube es gab
früher noch irgendwie sonne knopf dass
man schießen konnte aber den gibt's
nicht oder kann ich einfach so
jetzt könnt ihr mir vielleicht aber
vorher sagen dass man auch schießen kann
von daher jetzt mit ansage ein neuer
highscore kommentieren
es ist eigentlich echt easy wenn man
ruhiger hand hat bei sandra zum beispiel
ist ja immer irgendwie am zittern wegen
keine ahnung ob das vielleicht am
allgäuer den ganzen kippten liegt oder
so aber weil hier zb
[Musik]
der sorgt ein 1
er ist so wie diese löcher diese ufos
augen aber ich bin da ich bin da freunde
ich bin da und ich werde jetzt meinen
neuen highscore aufstellen ich habe
vorhin der seitlich ein 2014 sollten
egal wir sind ja eher am rand
eingeblendet gefordert das ding muss ich
auf jeden fall mitnehmen zack einmal fix
hoch zeigt weiter zweiter
schwiegermonster ich fahre einfach die
ganze nacht
[Musik]
guck mal da an
einfach der skills sind schon recht weit
auseinander mittlerweile sagt großmann
was war das 25.000 oder 21 auf menschen
vorbei ich weiß ist gerade nicht aber
gut wir lasst uns alles hier ann-kathrin
damit hier niemand hallo ich muss hier
braucht damit niemand irgendwie sagen
kann luca hier schummelt keine ahnung
was kommen gebt mir den wald wie heißt
du dieses ding im propeller wie heißt
dieser typ karlsson vom dach hier guck
mal wir sind schon mal über 95.000 was
ist das hier
[Musik]
ich bin so gut ich bin so gut ich bin so
gut sagt jetzt hier auf nachdenken
nachdenken darauf hier zu hoch ich kann
nur noch immer auf einen drauf springen
zwei schaffe ich nicht und das trampolin
dk es ist wahnsinn da fehlt noch das
video nicht mehr erst mal doodle jump
nennst du dich am weltrekord ganz klar
so wie letztens auf ein zweiter kanal wo
ich vorgestellt haben einfach neuen
highscore aufgestellt habe guck mal hier
rüber sagt monster jam hierhin hierhin
hier hin oh mein gott ich bin so gut ich
bin so gut das ist mein erstes mal
doodle jump nach 12 89 10 jahren oder so
und ich rasiere dieses spiel absolut
ja wie hoch ihr hoch sie mal
zwischendurch den checkpoint oder sowie
behalf er mario mein gott dass man sagen
kann
ich habe schon wieder in sound gehört
komisches aber dass man sagen kann okay
ich mache jetzt nichts mache ich hier
weiter oder so oder kriegt hier sondern
leben wenn man stirbt gibt es nicht ich
weiß gar nicht was hier noch
kommentieren soll habe ich das denn
früher geschafft also ganz ganz früh
aber nicht jetzt uncut videos hochladen
ich bin bei 35.000 hey wo sollen dass
die enden die pakete geht nicht okay
weiterspringen alles ist noch in
bewegung könnten nicht mehr solche
grünen teile machen oder irgendwas was
man mal kurz entspannen kann schon
wieder die jüngste verpasst die fehler
hier über europa hier die feder zack das
was grün ist aber ich würde dann vorbei
gesprungen perfekt ich kann jetzt aus
dem bild heraus so kuck mal heißt ich
wäre einfach nicht mehr sterben
ganz kurze time labs mal eben
[Musik]
an der stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat wie
ich zum ersten mal hier auf dem
youtube-kanal doodle jump gespielt habe
das kann einen daumen hoch unter diesem
video hier da abonniert main kanal und
klicken auf die glocken weitere videos
nicht zu verpassen ich
bin ganz ehrlich
spiel jetzt glaube ich einfach weiter